man who's has a secret Toombs have a
secret wasn't with sequels and their
secrets mad at the museum secret of the
tomb so this is the third night at the
Museum movies Ben Stiller he's a
security guard at night all the animals
and everything all the exhibits in this
museum come to life which is really cool
and that was a big thing as a big
production at night but the power that
makes it all happen solve with the ring
is going away why it's a secret of the
tomb not gonna tell you however does
give us a third adventure so here we go
and this movie was definitely more
entertaining than I thought it was gonna
be at this point third movie you know
everyone's gonna phone it in the way
alright let's get another paycheck and
have a bunch of CGI things running
around a bunch of historical figures
interacting with each other and it's
kind of the gimmick of the movie and
let's get a paycheck kind of is like
that still kind of entertaining maybe
I'm a big kid at heart I mean I know I'm
a big kid at heart when you have
Lancelot fighting a Triceratops skeleton
I'm like stem they're doing that I get
excited about that stuff we're gonna say
it does wear thin at some parks I mean
there are parts in this movie where
you're like oh it's really obvious where
they're going with that as mom was like
that that had draw - like hey idiot it's
not meant for you was meant for children
there is a caveman in this movie that
was meant for a comedic relief in a
comedy I don't know why unique comedy
relief in a comedy it was like the kind
of comedy though that was different than
the rest of the rest of the comedy you
feel like it's at least historically
speaking smart ish this caveman thing I
was like it's just dumb comedy it says
it's bringing the movie down if this
caveman wasn't in the movie the movie to
actually be pretty solid for kids and
adults as it stands it's more solid for
kids then you have the monkey peeing on
a couple of people and you're like uh
pee joke I got you Michael Bay thinks
that's funny and now he's in this movie
he took PG Oaks from us forever but then
the adult based references kick on
you're like oh I bet I don't think a
kid's gonna get that I'm laughing and
that kid doesn't know why moments like
that impressed me in a movie like this
well given the fact that the premise of
the movie is about a bunch of historical
figures and wax figures in a museum that
come to life at night so pretty by the
numbers kid adventure movie Magic's
going away they need to stop it and so
that's what they're trying to do the
things that like engage adults or the
relatability of human characters and
your hearts usually hearts it's a
general term but hard to bring
into a kids movie movie was kind of
lacking in that aspect and tell it
really excel than that and it's almost
it wasn't purposely done when the movie
was made at the end of the movies isn't
a spoiler really I mean you know at the
end of this movie they're all going
really alright goodbye goodbye when
they're saying their goodbyes robin
williams is in this movie and he's
saying his goodbyes and it's really
really sad it's just hard to watch I
mean you're people crying in the movie
theater when this is happening because
it's like Robin Williams is saying
goodbye to us but it made me glad I
watched the movie maybe go that was
worth seeing for sure kind of Eclipse
the rest of the movie took the movie to
a whole new direction worth like hey
we're here now in the end this movie had
some good jokes it has some good last
it's a fun adventure for kids but there
are some jokes that fall flat in some
parts where parents are just gonna roll
their eyes and were like alright this is
for the kids I'm gonna rate this movie
for kids because it's a children movie
made for kids if you yourself are a kid
I would say night at the museum's secret
of the tomb is a good time no alcohol
required yeah no [ __ ] because you're a
kid tonight at the museum secret of the
tomb have you seen it what did you think
about it what every thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more